we were locking in ventures with fortune
500 companies like procter gamble one of
the biggest global companies
hygiene companies in the um the world
and we were locking in
opportunities with those companies and i
still feel like i'm still that black
girl from working poor
shouldn't be here
um
this isn't for me you know i'm saying
like this wasn't this wasn't for me and
so um
i had to figure out how to
overcome that like even some and i think
it happens a lot to a lot of
entrepreneurs it's like when the best
seasons are happening there's something
else going on
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright xcel
serrano partners and in media
partnership with ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders meet renika
smiley founder and ceo of generation now
founder veronica j smiley first launched
generation now as a linkedin networking
happy hour event hosted at local bars
her first events featured a diverse
speaking panel and began with an
audience of 40 to 75 young professionals
in igb's private second floor
fortune 500 corporate offices soon
replaced igbes when attendance grew to
more than 200.
renika j smiley thank you so much for
joining me all the way from cincinnati
ohio how are you today
i am doing wonderful
thank you for uh
giving me this opportunity to speak
about leadership
thank you very very much ranika um you
know generation now you know i think
that there's such an interesting story
that i got to to to look into before we
did this
episode together and and i did
compliment you that you know i think
your last name is one of the best last
names i've ever i've ever seen and so uh
great great on that but tell me a little
bit about you know generation now and
how all of that started
okay so generation now well i'm i'm from
cincinnati
but i left cincinnati for a little while
i went to um i did a lot of traveling i
went a couple of different places
um i wounded up in chicago illinois and
atlanta georgia for a little while
um you know when you're in a new city
the only way you can really get to know
the city is if you google find out what
events is going on
and so um in chicago and atlanta there's
a lot of young professional uh events
there's a lot of networking going on
it's thriving energy energy in those
bigger cities
and so um i ended up coming back home to
cincinnati
after being a go in a go-getter market
and i'm already a go-getter and i seen
that there was still a big need
for that for young professionals in
cincinnati and especially inclusion
um in chicago and atlanta
i can be in a place with people from
different backgrounds different races
different sexualities you can bump
somebody by accident they're like okay
that's fine um you know sorry in
cincinnati if you bump somebody they're
like oh you know i'm saying because
they're not used to being in a diverse
and inclusive environment
and so um i started generation now with
a few of my friends
um they actually just came back to
cincinnati too we started out hosting an
event just uh like a happy hour
networking event and we had a panel
inside of the bar where we had like red
senior level speakers speaking
and um we end up growing from that to
hosting events at corporation offices
and actually uh developing cohort
programs and now we're membership-based
organizations tell me a little bit about
the
the first events that you've hosted what
were they like what did you learn from
the very first few events that you were
doing you know what surprised you what
was that experience like for you
so that experience the first few events
that we posted
um what i learned is that we were just
doing like the first program we launched
were just like monthly networking events
what i learned in those those first few
events is that a lot of young
professionals when they would add ask
the panelists questions they were just
questions about soft skills training
a lot of the question that young
professionals asked was really about
just how do they become more
professional how do they handle how do
they manage conflict
and so what i have seen in those first
few events is that um young
professionals need more cohort programs
for for professional development
training
that would help them understand
um what i've seen in the first few
months which landed us sponsorships with
big corporation fortune 500 companies in
cincinnati
is that
there was a lack of diversity inclusion
um the young professionals loved our
events because you can come to our
events no matter your background no
matter where you came from and you can
feel comfortable and you can network
with new people and it was really good
for people coming from even bigger city
markets are actually um
young professionals who were new to the
city it was easier way for them to get
connected in the community
and so
was that surprising to you or was that
of the thesis that you had from the
get-go about generation now and about
you know what this generation needs
yeah well um one of my skills is a knack
for problem solving so i actually can
pick out problems
and actually solve them and so i seen
that that was a big huge solution in
cincinnati that was needed not just in
cincinnati as needed in other markets uh
just to kind of help young professionals
grow especially now since we're in a
workforce where um we have the great
resignation
we have a lack of people actually
working now we have more people
actually um one of our businesses and so
it's it's kind of it's growing the
economy but it's hurting the economy at
the same time because if everyone's an
entrepreneur then we won't have any
employees
that makes a lot of sense now
tell me a little bit about the scale
that you that you've used here so how
did you know what was the process like
for you to scale to start getting those
sponsorships to start working with those
corporations and what did you learn from
that experience of scaling
absolutely so for scaling being that
this was my second business and i
actually came from like
working poor first business was as a
nightlife club promoter
um it took me a little longer to kind of
transition
and uh learn how to kind of manage and
grow a non-for-profit
and so how we scaled the not-for-profit
uh we actually
just decided to just continue to host
events have networking events and
actually do soft skill training uh
workshops for young professionals just
to kind of keep them engaged
and the actual corporations begin to
like sponsor our events to continue
keeping the uh events going and so what
i ended up learning in that time
when we were hosting events is that
that's a really hard way to kind of grow
an organization it's a hustle because
you're hustling from events to events to
events to events to events to kind of
pay the budget and keep the organization
going so um we had to pivot and really
uh
transition the business model into more
of a workforce development
membership based business model which
helps us out a lot because
there is other young professional kind
of membership based organizations across
the country in the united states that's
similar to generation now but what makes
generational difference different is
that we also have a uh workforce
development uh proportion of it which
we're not only just training young
professionals and corporate
organizations we're actually contracting
partnering with school systems
partnering with um human service
organizations to train their actual uh
young professionals that go through
their programs who are trying to come
you know make it out of poverty make it
out of work and poor and so a lot of the
issues with human services organizations
they're great organizations
but they have like a branding and a
stigma
that
once you go through a human service
organization
the highest they can get you is probably
a job being a bagger at kroger's or at a
grocery store
generation now we have the brand you
know that is
for young professionals who are thriving
and trying to get to the next level
within their career and so the brand of
generational helps even the working
class or the lower middle class young
professionals who want to actually
develop so now have now how we have
scaled today is
pivot into a membership-based
organization where the corporations pay
for memberships for their young
professional employees
you can pay for individual memberships
um of course with the corona virus
everything is digital if you don't have
a digital component component it's gonna
kind of slow you down
and so uh we are creating now an
application for generation now the
digital component where once our members
log in and you pay a membership
you can take courses you can visit our
job board you can uh you're welcome to
come to workshops where you can meet
employers who run information workshops
to let you know about job opportunities
that are available
um and then you can network with uh
people on the website like we have the
the uh kind of like the facebook the
news feeds where you can kind of accept
friends meet people and um you can
actually connect with people
for like coaching or projects that you
need or mentorship
if you're looking back and reflecting on
you know the trajectory of generation
now and what's happened there and and
how you grew and expanded
from events to a community to now
offering these digital services and a
digital community a virtual community
that is that that is here to empower
this generation and in a much more
impactful way than a lot of other
organizations do
what what were sort of can you pinpoint
some aha moments that you've had along
the journey where you or your team
members you know just something happened
and you knew that there was a potential
here you knew
that something big can come out of this
if you just continue and push forward
um the aha moment that i had was
actually about our digital component it
was um actually a idea that we had in
mind about two three years ago
and um
that idea was uh with my friend he
actually is a
uh alumni for the 30 under 30 forbes
list he's uh the founder of tech company
wiser
and so um he he went through the
the um
brandary accelerator program in in
cincinnati and i remember when i was
talking to bk simmons he was like hey
you should probably create a digital
component to what you're doing with
generation now that was probably about
like three years ago and i was like yeah
i think i could and i'm actually still i
actually spoke to uh bk a couple other
day a couple of days ago because i'm
like i need some help here i need you to
help me you you started and scaled your
technology business to like five ten
million dollars i need you to help me
with some of uh the stuff that we're
doing because we're getting ready to
pitch for um
a few different capital opportunities to
really expand it uh digital component so
i think that was probably
um
the best aha moment and and it just was
perfect timing with cove with um a lot
of jobs are now remote because so now
it's harder to connect with people so we
had to create something digitally to
still
connect with people
what was the most challenging piece of
it all until now if you're looking at
the whole journey
what is the most challenging thing that
you had to overcome or still overcoming
as an entrepreneur
um
i think still overcoming as an
entrepreneur
in poster syndrome
um
in
bootstrapping coming from an environment
where
you don't have a lot of people you can
call for help and you have to
kind of um figure it out financially or
figure out funding yourself
um
i believe the um
the most challenging piece was not for
profit in cincinnati it has got better
in the last two three years but
cincinnati lacks a huge resources for
non-for-profits so that was kind of um
one of the hindrance that we have with
generation now and a lot of
not-for-profit organizations in
cincinnati if you want to get a
not-for-profit started it was really
hard it wasn't a lot of resources
available
but um thankfully for um local
organizations such as uh leadership uh
council for not-for-profits
uh one source and even uh
um
what's the other one social venture
partners who's actually pivot their
models to help give more support to uh
to actually uh not for profits it has
really helped us out a lot
tell me a little bit about the the
imposter syndrome that you mentioned
before because i think that is something
that
every entrepreneur has i know every
entrepreneur has and i think it's
something that you know case is
something that is always
difficult to understand
especially for somebody who's not going
through the entrepreneurial experience
but i think that is something that is so
and it's so important to sort of
understand and to say okay yes we know
we have it but that's okay we can still
move forward with it we can learn with
it and we can grow into it
what was that like for you or still is
like for you
um imposter syndrome
now for me it's still
um about feeling like do i know
do i know do am i making the right
choice am i making the right decision
am i really hearing from the lord
because i am a woman by i'm a woman of
faith so i follow god and so um i feel
like he gives us the plan of what to do
and so i'm like you know that's why i
reach out to like okay am i doing the
right thing
i know before um
it was a lot of anxiety i used to have
panic attacks even in the beginning when
i was like we were locking in ventures
with fortune 500 companies like procter
gamble one of the biggest global
companies
hygiene companies in the um the world
and we were locking in
opportunities with those companies and i
still feel like i'm still that black
girl from working poor
shouldn't be here
um
this isn't for me you know i'm saying
like this wasn't this wasn't for me and
so um
i had to figure out how to overcome that
like even some and i think it happens a
lot to a lot of entrepreneurs it's like
when the best seasons are happening
there's something else going on
but um i know what has helped me out is
uh psychology understanding a lot like i
just recently was diagnosed
with um
depression and anxiety i didn't know
that i had depression and anxiety and
now that i have
been actually learning how to deal with
those
challenges that i that i just became
aware of
um
now i understand okay a lot of the
things i would think the lot of the
things that i was thinking was more of
um
less of insecurity so i'm thinking oh
this is insecurity like oh this is maybe
i have low self-esteem that's the
impulsive imposter syndrome when a lot
of it was just anxiety
and so um
and that's what i'm going to school for
now is psychology too
so um i learned a lot is a lot of our
decision making a lot of the
challenges that we have
um is really getting to the the
nitty-gritty of those
issues and finding a way to
unconditionally love ourselves no matter
what we're going through
and so i think that's the um
that's the most um
coolest opportunity yet you can find
to be able to be um the best version of
yourself to perform with your business
is really getting to the uh the
nitty-gritty of the personal issues
that's bothering you this is all the
motivational videos that you see on
youtube
all education all the self-help books
that that's all they're doing is helping
you become a better version of yourself
so
those distractions or the blind sides
that you're having
they they won't bother you so much
so it's a lot of soul-searching that you
have to do in a lot of it that i found
out is really just courage
if you were to go back in time
and give yourself one one tip
from your experience what would that tip
be
one tip from my experience that if i had
to go back
and uh talk to ranika i would tell
renika
it's gonna be okay
like you're gonna get there
um enjoy
life don't
run yourself to the ground
enjoy the moments enjoy every single
moment it's all great moments
um that was one of the hugest issues i
had with depression and i think a lot of
entrepreneurs go through is uh
with being anti-social
working so much
that you work so much alone that you can
isolate yourself and that's kind of what
happened to me as a young professional
um things were falling apart a few years
ago but i i can't believe i still was
like the the you know it's like um
the roof the waters coming out of the
roof and the sky is falling on you and
you're just holding it up like
i it doesn't matter how bad
this thing gets i'ma just keep holding
my hands up like this that's that's how
i felt at the time
but um
i end up having um a mental breakdown
moment and i had to uh
really get myself back together and have
to understand that balance and i'm a
libra too
um but balance balance is really
important
to really balance your life out and just
enjoy those moments
uh because the isolation being an
entrepreneur even being a ceo or a
leader at a company it can uh really
take a toll on you
so
i think that's what i want to talk about
i want to thank you you know we came
into this conversation talking about
generation now we're leaving it with
what i think is
the epitome of leadership which is
being able to share you know honestly
and authentically these experiences
that are common to so many people and
it's so uncommon to hear about them in
an authentic and honest way and i really
want to thank you for for being
vulnerable here and for opening yourself
up and for
be willing to share with me and with
anybody who's listening you know a
glimpse of the of the struggles that
also happen
uh but more importantly you know the the
looking back
and saying okay it's okay now we can
enjoy the moments it's all about one big
journey
let's love the moments and and uh and if
we truly enjoy them and and harness them
that'll be the best thing that will
propels forward so renika thank you very
very much um again love your last name i
i'm gonna i wish i had a last name like
smile i think it's uh fantastic and
leaving on an optimistic note and the
best of luck with generation now thank
you for all the amazing work that you're
doing and stay safe and stay healthy
absolutely thank you so much thank you
for the opportunity to be a feature in
20 minutes so i'm super excited
to uh see where this opportunity takes
you with uh how you expand it so i
enjoyed watching the previous clips of
other uh shows
of uh 20 leaders and and i'm like okay
this is a really cool thing
thank you very very much
thank you anytime no problem